no no no if it's on camera we're not
doing an interview why we'll explain why
how do you feel about that influence
that you had you better be careful we're
coming for your children there buddy
about Maring Nation yes I'm going to do
you're going to Res I'm going I've been
answering your question you answer mine
it's actually not my job to answer your
questions thank God for talk TV is not
only the home of common sense it's the
only place where you get the
[Music]
truth on t t v on Radio and on your
smartphone this is talk
TV tonight I'm appears Morgan
unsensitive Israel faces growing demands
for a ceasefire as death and destruction
in Gaza intensifies how can it eradicate
Hamas without killing many more innocent
people how far can it go without losing
international support what happens to
Gaza if it wins these are Big questions
tonight I've got a big guest who needs
to have some big answers I'll talk to
the Israeli president Isaac Hof
oneon-one
[Music]
well good evening from London welcome to
Piers Morgan on sensor with every
Israeli air strike and hail of bullets
on Gaza with every devastating image of
death and destruction the calls for a
ceasefire grow louder Fury Israel's
response to the October 7th terrorist
attack is spilling onto our streets
anti-Semitic attacks of skyro rocketed
many of those Marching for Palestine
believe they're Marching for peace and
they have every right to to protest
peacefully but plenty among them are
using these demonstrations as cover for
deeply unsettling views and the rest of
us have every right to feel
uncomfortable about scenes like this
smash
stash
[Music]
stash well more than 9,700 Palestinians
have been reportedly killed since
October the 7th including after to 4,000
children that's according to the Hamas
run authorities in Gaza whatever the
exact number it's clear that Israel is
inflicting monstrous civilian casualties
the ground Invasion and the Israeli
blockade of fuel clean water and food
threaten the lives of many thousands
more statements like this from a now
suspended minister in netanyahu's
government make it sound like the ground
offensive is more about vengeance and
security Mr minister in your opinion
there are no innocent people in Gaza
therefore humanitarian Aid should not be
provided for them that is one option the
other is to check what is important to
them what scares them what will create
the next deterrent for them the fact
that you kill them and they are not
afraid of death we must remember that
the gazans can go to Ireland or deserts
the monsters in Gaza should find a
solution by
themselves these are all powerful
Arguments for a ceasefire with a bit of
Truth is Israel must defend itself when
Israelis talk about an existential
threat they mean it literally Hamas
wants to wipe Israel from the face face
of the Earth from the river to the Sea
they chant they couldn't be clearer
Israel has a unique duty to its people
something the rest of us can only try to
understand Jewish people have faced
centuries of pilgrims persecution and
displacement and the Holocaust the state
of Israel exists to provide a land where
Jewish people know they can live safely
and without fear of being murdered for
their faith but amass has proven that it
will murder Israelis with impunity
knowing full well that many Palestinians
will die in consequence and it's been
chillingly clear that he won't hesitate
before doing so
again the existence of Israel is what
causes all the pain Blood and
Tears it is Israel not us we are the
victims of the occupation period on
October 7 October 10 October million
again and again everything we do is
Justified so peace with Hamas is
impossible Israelis will never feel safe
again that unique duty to the Jewish
people is existentially compromised it
will strike Gaza whenever it feels at
risk and as it's doing now Hamas will
hide his leaders among civilians and
fire Rockets from Moss schools and water
plants Palestinians will be radicalized
and a cycle of violence and tragedy will
continue Israel needs to destroy Hamas
but it also needs to build the
foundations for something new that means
recognizing that Palestinians deserve a
state too it means curbing Israeli
settlers in the West Bank recognizing
the long oppression of the Palestinian
people it means new leadership on both
sides I support Israel's right to
self-defense I also believe Israel needs
to win this war against Hamas but how it
wins the war matters deeply the people
of Gaza need proper Aid and real safe
zones the rest of the world needs proof
that Israel can do this without
catastrophic civilian deaths and by
obeying international law right now it's
facing more questions than it has
answers well tonight I'm putting those
questions to Isaac herzo the president
of Israel who I interviewed earlier
today it's a powerful and at times
emotional interview with the head of
State who doesn't mince his
words and I'm joined now by the
president of Israel Isaac Herzog Mr
President thank you very much indeed for
joining me uh I appreciate you're
obviously very busy at the moment and I
I appreciate you taking my time to talk
to us let me start by uh taking you back
to October the 7th the day that was a
catalyst for this new war where were you
that day and when did you hear about
what had
happened
it was uh 6:30 in the morning I was
planning uh to wake up at around 7:30
because it was a holiday a Saturday and
a vacation actually the entire week
before was a national vacation because
it was the Feast of
Tabernacles and um I was planning to go
to synagogue to celebrate the new
opening of the Bible as we read each
week a portion of the Bible so it was
Genesis and um
Sirens broke the sirens in the entire
neighborhood were Torn to Pieces by
immense sirens and then booms and Booms
and Booms we immediately realized that
we are under mile attack it was a huge
missile attack in highsight we know that
there was well over 2,000 missiles
launched at all of Israel from Gaza and
the shock was huge but we thought we ran
to the shelters but we didn't know
whether there was anything else we
assumed okay missile attack for some
reason I was telling my wife there's a
missile attack and um then we opened the
TV and started getting the news endless
news about atrocities all throughout our
Southern border about people being
locked in in shelters and burnt and and
and and under attack and they call they
call the emergency services they call
the uh Studios of Television they speak
to the Anchorman who's on the on TV
saying save us help us help us we're
we're under attack we're being booked we
hear the enemy we hear Arabic behind the
door etc etc and whole hell broke loose
we've gone through the worst atrocity as
a nation since the establishment of the
state of Israel the highest amount of
Jews killed since the Holocaust about
eight or nine times 911 in terms of our
national proportion of casualties but it
doesn't end the cup is filled with
poison it doesn't end we feel we meet
families all the time you know I met the
uh go the almog Goldstein family you
have three generations grandparents
parents children and many abducted and
also killed and missing and it goes on
and on and on all the time you read a
piece in the New York Times about this
and you talked about going to one of the
Kuts which were attacked and how you had
to wash blood off your shoes and how the
meetings you had with the families of
those who've been taken hostage were the
most difficult meetings of your life
tell me about that in Berry when I went
in to see the Havoc the atrocities the
burning homes in one of the homes when I
walked in there was a pool of blood
still drying there were sculpts there
was a woman's sculpts with a rake
holding it that shows how atrocious
these people were how villains they are
how crazy animalistic and barbaric and
sadistics they are and you walk and the
the the house is totally ruined but you
see a picture of grandparents and
parents and
children in hanging on the security room
where they had this their sh shelter and
the shelter was of course totally burnt
and I assume there one of the burning
bodies there I mean families were tied
up in barred briers and burned together
I could only think what they said to the
almighty before they parted Earth and
then I I went and I since then I keep on
meeting families of the
hostages endless
stories why would a 9 Monon old baby be
hijacked now he's already 10 his
grandmother told us sorry he's 10 months
old okay why would Leah three month 3
years old be hijacked where all her
family is being killed they just took
her and so forth and so on endless
stories of atrocities on the one hand
and the worst of all is not knowing the
fate of your loud one on the other hand
and C clear crime against humanity clear
genocide took place in that area
incidentally the biggest peac loving
area in Israel and where the center of
the peace movement was your father himim
who later became president of Israel and
in fact you're the only father and son
to ever achieve that highest office um
he was in the British Army in World War
II as an intelligence officer in the
armored formations he fought the Nazi
he took part in the Normandy invasion he
helped liberate Holland and Belgium
amongst other things he helped capture
heinrick himler one of the main
architects of the Holocaust he took part
in the liberation of the Bergen bellson
concentration camp and he talked about
when he when he was at bellson uh
telling the survivors he was a Jewish
officer from Palestine and how they
burst into tears at this and you have
said before I'll never forget how he
described to me the horrors that unfold
holded before his eyes as one of the
first liberators of the death camps
including ber and bsum the human
skeletons in the Striped Pajamas the
hell on Earth EST stench the Heart of
Darkness and you were asked once what
advice you thought your father would
give to Future generations and he said
never take the state of Israel for
granted did did you ever imagine when
your father was telling you these
stories that you yourself would walk
into a scene like you did in that kabut
which was so reminiscent of of the
horrors of the
Holocaust thank you for reminding this
to me it's quite moving for me because
my dad always spoke about these
moments my father joined the British
Army in order to fight the Nazis he was
a student in in at
Cambridge and the war broke out he also
served as a in the blitz within you know
know in London the as guarding the
streets he always spoke about the
immense resilience of the British people
and their constant attacks and then of
course wrote to his parents that he's
joining the British army to fight the
Nazi enemy and and save Jews and his
experience in Bergen bellson which was
the one of the greatest horrors of
humanity there were piles of bodies of
skeletons Dead skeletons there has
depicted the the awful smell of the
atrocities at burken bellson and the
fact that when he walked in truly the
the survivors they thought that he is a
Nazi
perpetrator when and he had to turn them
to them in Hebrew and Yiddish which is a
Jewish German language to tell them I'm
a Jewish officer from the land of Israel
coming to save you and there are still
Jews in the world so that's why it was
imprinted in his being and that's how he
passed it on to me and to our families
never take the Jewish state for granted
this is our safe haven that's where Jews
from all over the world from well over
100 countries came forward and
reestablished the ancient Homeland and
and the lesson I took from my father is
never never again Jews will not accept
the Jewish state will not accept these
atrocities Within its borders killing
its citizens and we have complained and
and said and mentioned endlessly to the
world that we are under Terror attacks
constantly almost 10,000 missiles were
launched at us since we pulled out of
Gaza in 2007 all from Hamas we've we've
alerted the entire universe and the
family of Nations that there's an Empire
of evil from tan emanating with the
whole culture of hate to eradicate all
of us and I say to my friends all over
the world especially in Europe guys if
it weren't for us Europe would be next
because the culture of hate that these
guys have brought forward Isis alqaeda
Hamas and Islamic Jihad and the hutis in
Yemen and the entire culture of hate
simply wants all of us out they don't
accommodate Jews Christians or or even
moderate Muslims they are seeing the
inclusion of Israel in the region a
vision of Peace which we all believe in
as a threat to them and most importantly
they are want all they want is to chop
our heads and get to you guys next this
is the real challenge of the world
today
[Music]
[Applause]
one of the most extraordinary things to
witness uh as a non-jew I'm an Irish
Catholic looking at all this but within
hours of what happened uh there were
Mass protests all around the world from
New York to Sydney where there were
people chanting Gast to Jews in Sydney
one of the great cities of the world in
London there were protests in my High
Street up near the Israeli Embassy Mass
protests with many people celebrating
what had happened and I found that
unconscionable that any human being's
first reaction to this appalling terror
attack would be one of Jubilation we
then saw us professors at American
universities one at Cornell caught on
camera saying how exhilarated he felt by
what had happened we've seen students
again American universities beaming
pramas rhetoric onto campus walls we've
seen Jewish students barricading
themselves in libraries for fear of
their safety from from chanting mobs and
in these protests in in London and New
York and others many many people there
at Pro Palestinian protest chanting
Jihad and from The River To The Sea when
you see all this as a reaction to this
calling attack on Israel how does that
make you
feel you know I was talking to my wife
the other day I still remember September
93 in September 193 13th September there
was a ceremony at the White House
lawn but where prime minister it's Rabin
and the leader of the Palestinian
national movement Arafat shook hands
under the hospices of President Clinton
and signed the osaw Accords or started
them and there was and the entire nation
was watching it and I was telling then
my wife we had a baby we had two babies
this you know what perhaps our children
will not have to
fight well that reality has been shuted
long
ago and we understand that we always
will have to fight and um as opposed to
um previous generations we have now the
state of Israel and we have the tools to
fight and Jews can fight all over the
world Jews are threatened I have friends
from all corners of the earth people I
grew up with I studied with they are
extremely frightened and and and I had
friends including one of your most
distinguished colleagues who was in
Israel last week told me I feel much
safer in Israel he's Jewish
now this is unacceptable because history
teaches us that anti-Semitism is always
the beginning but the tragedies unfold
to all other human beings this is the
greatest disease of humanity
anti-Semitism is the greatest disease of
humanity what these people are chanting
is not only immoral and unjust but it's
reflection of their own knowledge of
things or their own moral compass how
could you justify truly how could you
justify chopping children's heads how
could you
justify burning entire Families how
could you justify raping women of all
ages and taking them hostage how could
you justify tearing off people's women's
and men's sculps how could you justify
these horrific atrocities broadcast
casting broadcasting live how you carry
out these
atrocities taking a mother's iPhone and
broadcasting to the entire her entire
WhatsApp group how you are torturing her
husband her killing her daughter and and
her and her B and her young children and
this goes on and on and on this is a
test for Humanity and a moral call for
moral clarity and human beings and
leaders must be outraged and understand
that when you give a nation the right
for selfdefense it has a right for
self-defense the American congresswoman
Rashida Talib tweeted from the river to
the sea is an aspirational call for
Freedom human rights and peaceful
coexistence not death destruction or
hate what is your response to
that she simply above everything else I
mean all these atrocious comments all
this terrible view of
things she simply doesn't know
history the world recognized the Jewish
State's rights for Independence in dece
in November
1947 in the UN General Assembly the
family of Nations accepted they are our
borders were of course agreed that
border was
violated by this terror attack and we've
strived for peace all throughout since
then we've extended our hands for peace
we signed peace agreement we defended
ourselves we fought for peace we were
willing to go for peace but
unfortunately the entire culture of hate
the culture of jihad Jihad may I remind
you about John The jihadist Who simply
would show the entire world how he takes
a prisoner and cuts his head that's what
Jihad is all about when people chant
pres not a revolutionary moment when
people chant from The River To The Sea
what does that mean to
you that that means annihilating Israel
because we have the Jordan River and the
Mediterranean
Sea this is of course a call to
annihilate the state of Israel the only
nation state of the Jewish people on
Earth the Jewish people have founded
this state after returning to their
ancient Homeland rebuilding it
and re being recognized by the
International Community
unfortunately following the worst
atrocity of humanity which is the
Holocaust where six million of our
people were burnt gassed killed and
tortured and and killed by all sorts of
the most terrible means when in in in
the most violent attack Humanity has
seen where whereby the forces of good
LED by the United States of America by
the British the United Kingdom of course
by the USSR in those days they all and
together with all other nations had to
fight the Nazis and their allies and
liberate Europe and that brought the
change in the world that brought the
creation of the United Nations that led
to the human rights Charter that brought
to the uh definition of what genocide is
all about and crimes against humanity
well a new world order was created well
the world order is being challenged and
challenged dramatically on and this is
the real challenge in facing all leaders
of the world guys don't be mistaken you
have to be tough and strong to fight
this evil on Saturday it's armis state
in uh the UK a very important day where
we obviously commemorate and honor those
who sacrificed the their lives in in the
wars um your father undoubtedly would
have lost people that were close to him
when he served in the World War II uh
how do you feel about the fact there was
a a pro Palestinian March a big one
planned to take part take place on
Saturday on Armistice Day in London
there are calls here from many people
now for this march to be banned because
many of the people Marching In These
marches have been chanting G had from
The River To The Sea and other things
like
that it's a atrocious and
hypocritic and I call upon all decent
human beings to object to the March and
ban it because the symbol of that day is
a symbol of Victory and it's it's a
symbol of doing good because when you
fight evil sometimes you have to fight
you have to to fight evil in order to
uproot evil unfortunately we live with
evil throughout the ages and um what we
are seeing constantly is unbelievable
evil unbelievable evil we've seen Terror
we've been harassed by Terror all our
lives terror is what stopped the Israeli
Palestinian
peace terror is what undermines peace we
were in a historic process for the last
50 years of inclusion of Israel in the
region of peace agreements with Egypt
with Jordan and the the Accords with the
Palestinians the Abraham Accords which
of course four other Arab Nations signed
with us United Arab Emirates the kingdom
of bahin the kingdom of Morocco and
Sudan they all signed with us agreements
we were moving forward we had serious H
deliberations about the possibility of
signing a peace agreement with with
Saudi Arabia in and
normalization well this attack is part
of a grand scheme to undermine this
process of inclusion doing peace and
turn the region into a region of war and
that is why World Community has to be
forceful and strong and oppose all these
efforts and move strongly towards the
inclusion of Israel in the region while
giving security to Israel and all its
neighbors commend world leadership I
commend President Joe Biden prime
minister Rishi sunna and the opposition
leaders starmer and prime minister and
president of France mcon and many others
of course who have stood up with us
against this process of evil and this is
the test of humanity and the entire
world Community these
days
[Music]
we're here good morning everybody hope
you're well thanks for joining us you're
watching the independent republic of
Mike gra right here on talk TV welcome
to Friday night with nine here on prime
time we like to speak to the business
people behind big moments good evening
I'm Pi Morgan uncensored in New York
City very impressive well
played I'm 3 days into the job what have
I done right and your face just starred
out at me me and you conquer time who
wins you do you know what I love about
toour today we do it all sunak sella
scon are you actually speech writing for
richy sunak I'm so rich frankly uh I'm
going to take the side of boozed up
Brits against these pompous you mean
you're not going to support mayor Jose L
am
not stop panding to the nimes to the
naysayers and The National Society part
for the preservation of the habitat of
the Lesser spotted M the problem lies in
the bureaucracy it's almost like there
highly paid Consultants don't really
know what they're
doing the first thing they teach you in
weather school is never confuse dog
walkers with Doggers Twitter you sons of
can you please reinstate my account
thank you there's a threat that you'd be
worried about so are you saying that
you're being overwhelmed that you're
inundated we are really working hard for
you we're just asking patients to be
patient with us are we only going to be
trusting sources like meta and Google
and Facebook and X formly known as
Twitter where is our where is our
unbiased news going to come from Welcome
to the talk it's really great to be back
my Little Darlings kids think all they
have to do is stay at home be silly take
pictures of everything just shut down
Tik Tok then yeah problem problem solved
there you go who's fit as a butchest do
him all right but but he's now middle
class us here Tess I nearly have empathy
when I'm speaking to them I know now
you're probably going to boot me after
show
this Kevin O Sullivan is the worst
presenter on talk TV sitting on his fat
ass talking for
living got former PMS all over the joint
saying things the last few days we have
indeed yeah great first show you having
fun oh a ton of fun King PE and King
Cube I think it's only room for one king
man you know what I'm saying just cuz
they're skin folk don't mean they're kin
Folk when I say I am God you think I'm
joking or not you tell me I'm not joking
I'd rather do it on camera no no no no
if it's on camera we're not doing an
interview why we'll explain why how do
you feel about that influence that you
had you better be careful we're coming
for your children there buddy they all
Maring Nation yes I'm going to do you're
going to resign I'm going I've been
answering your question you answer mine
it's actually not my job to answer your
questions thank God for talk TV is not
only the home of common sense it's the
only place where you get the truth
[Music]
truth this is talk
TV let me talk now Mr President about
Israel's response because I wanted to
give you enough time to really explain
how you feel as the president of a
country that suffered that terror attack
and you've done so very evocatively and
very powerfully but as you know there is
Moun con concern over the the the scale
of Israel's response to what happened
many people talking and asking the
question what is proportionate in your
mind is there any response that could be
deemed proportionate or will you do
whatever it takes as a country to
eradicate
Hamas so first let's understand the
rules of international law because most
of the Nations tell us you have the
right to defend yourself
we are speaking about almost 20 years of
bombardments from Gaza on and off
ceasefires agreements operations
Wars while looking for ways and means to
change the equation to war
peace Gaza was taken over in 2007 by
brutal coup of Hamas it was taken out
from the hands of the Palestinians
Palestinian Authority which is
controlled by fat movement and then they
literally butchered their family members
and took over Hamas and leading it into
a platform of War by Iran they filled it
up with ammunition rather than doing
anything possible to help their own
people and upgrade their living
standards they kept on fighting and
fighting in the last two years there was
progress Israel agreed for the first
time to open up Gaza for gazan employees
to come to work in Israel
tens of thousands of Gins were employed
in Israel and money flowed in they broke
bread and money flowed in then the
economy economy grew little did we
understand
naively that many of those working in
Israel also collected and gathered
information about their
employees
had given information to Hamas as to
where each house is where to land with
your gliders how to break into your
fence and how to get to the cities and
towns in which they worked in and the
money that they they took and they and
all the income from your taxpayers money
for international projects in Gaza was
basically used and taken by Hamas to
build this machine of a of Cruelty and
barbarism Mr President let me just say
7th of October let me just say Mr
President I I completely agree that
Hamas should be eradicated I think most
right-minded people can understand that
there can never be peace now after what
Hamas did on October the 7th but like I
say many people are looking at Israel's
response now nearly 10,000 Palestinians
have been killed since October the 7th
these are figures I must say which are
reported by the Hamas control
Palestinian Health Ministry they say
nearly 4,000 children have been killed
we know know that uh on Saturday night
the AL magazi refugee camp which is just
to the South uh was bombed uh reportedly
50 so people let me explain well let me
ask you on that one specifically I don't
think there's been a response yet by
Israel Hamas say that was an Israeli air
strike is that true and it how do you
justify bombing somewhere that is known
to be a refugee
camp we don't I'm not aware of this at
all and a lot there's a lot of fake
coming out of Kamas information channels
but first let me explain to you what we
what what's happening when you have the
right for self-defense you have the
right for self-defense we have been
attacked from people's homes we have
been attacked from schools from mosques
from shops and people's living rooms now
you are your viewers do they have a bomb
do they have a missile do they have a
mortar in their living rooms there are
missile launchers that send missiles 200
kilm that must be a huge missile I
yesterday tweeted as our forces have
have walked into a theme park and a
playground for children where they found
launchers in the ground ready to launch
missiles on our children and I say
specifically if they are ready to launch
missiles on our children we must go and
eradicate that site same goes for the
houses now how do we behave according to
International humanitarian law we we
alert the citizens we tell them in your
home there's a missile launcher get out
of your home go down to the safe Zone in
southern Gaza you are getting enough
humanitarian Aid and we will eradicate
that infrastructure of Hamas we sent
millions of leaflets we called and texts
and messages and whatsapps and smss and
phone calls by 10 million number Mr
President let me
people go down so at the end at the end
we have to go out and we have to go in
and eradicate that infrastructure of
course we check ourselves with lawyers
and jurists we try to make as safe as
possible not to hurt civilians and
believe me and I say it outright from
the bottom of my heart we care for every
civilian in Gaza I care and I can tell
you stories about me helping gazan
citizens all throughout my career but
with all du respect there comes a moment
where you have no other choice because
if we will recur again we'll go through
the same atrocities again but I
understand Mr presid to be clear
eradicated as I said I absolutely
support Israel's right to defend itself
in fact I think you have a duty as a
country uh to and a responsibility to
your people to try and stop Hamas doing
again what they did and only last week a
Hamas spokesman said that they would try
again and again and again to replicate
what happened on October the 7th so you
don't need to keep telling me how bad
herass are I get it and they have to go
it's just how you do this and that is
what is coming under criticism Queen Ria
of Jordan has called for an immediate
ceasefire in a new interview she says
there has to be a collective call for a
ceasefire I know some who are against a
ceasefire arguing it will help Hamas
however in that argument they are
inherently dismissing the deaths and in
fact endorsing and justifying the deaths
of thousands of civilians that's not
just morally reprehensible shortsighted
and not entirely uh rational if Israel
she says managed to eliminate all of
herass the root cause of this conflict
is its illegal occupation and routine
human rights abuses illegal settlements
disregard to un resolutions and
international law if we do not address
the root causes you can kill the
combatant but you cannot kill the cause
what is your response to Queen Ria
I I don't intend to start arguing with
Ken Ria because I you know I know
exactly uh the considerations and the
limitations of the Jordanian regime
under the circumstances but I would
expect a much better understanding of
the situation on the ground first of all
there must be no justification under any
circumstances none whatsoever to the
atrocities that we have seen and gone
through and no justification to Terror
none whatsoever by the way this hate
regime that attacked us the the first
thing they'll do unfortunately they'll
try to attack Jordan as well we're all
in this together they'll try to attack
other regimes as well they're all in
this together We're All in This Together
We Are All Nations who want to move to
peace and we're attacked by this
philosophy of hate of al-Qaeda Isis
Kamas Jihad and the rest they want all
of us out of here and they all want all
of us wiped off and they want a major
Islamic fundamentalist regime throughout
the Middle East that's the real story
and that's the real challenge with all
the respect regarding settlements and
all the these are issues that have been
discussed in a priest process they
should be discussed in a priest process
there are many ideas to have peace with
it between us and the Palestinians and
how to move towards the solutions such
as the two-state solution but it cannot
happen if you support or if you give any
credit in any way directly or indirectly
to Terror we cannot accept Terror we
have to fight Terror and then when we
fight Terror we can sit down and talk we
tried sitting down and talking for
decades
already remember in the 1990s PE in the
1990s I remember in the 1990s teror
suicide bombers killed the process
that's the same like now that's the
tactics that's how they do it but there
are many people entire region to fight
their I understand that and I like I say
I agree with the mission statement to
get rid of herass but I share people's
concern about the sheer scale of what is
going on in Gaza not least the mounting
humanitarian crisis you have over a
million people whose homes have been
displaced Angelina Jolie the actress is
also a special Envoy to the UN High
commission for refugees she said this
this is the deliberate bombing of a
trapped population who have nowhere to
flee gazra has been in open air prison
for nearly two decades and is fast
becoming a mass grave 40% of those
killed are innocent children whole
families are being murdered while the
world watches and with the active
support of many governments millions of
Palestinian civilians children women
families are being collectively punished
and dehumanized all while being deprived
of food medicine and humanitarian Aid
against international law by refusing to
demand humanarian CE and blocking the UN
Security Council from imposing one on
both parties world leaders are complicit
in these crimes so she's saying that you
are committing war crimes here what do
you say to
that that I totally reject her claims I
think she's never been in Gaza she's
never been here she never went to visit
and see the facts on the ground with all
the respect people in Gaza know there is
war but there is no
humanitarian crisis that are not that
that that does not enable them to
survive on the contr there's a safe Zone
which was agreed by the International
Community in Israel in the South part of
Gaza in order to move the citizens to
that zone to take full care of them
there's a major dramatic increase in
humanitarian Aid to Gaza which Israel
has supported
dramatically in conjunction with the
United States and United Nations and
many other nations the gazan the gazan
people are they can move there so that
we uproot this Terror regime this is
what we know Angelina Jolie does not
offer the Israeli people any ability to
defend themselves by saying what she is
saying and may I speak about her comment
that Gaza is a is is a jail Gaza is a
jail not because of his Israel Israel
pulled out of Gaza to the last inch Gaza
is an Iranian base filled with Terror
smuggled with tons and tons and tons of
ammunition this is the tragedy that has
befallen the gazen people perhaps the
outcome of this war will enable the
gazan people who deserve decent good
life to enjoy it under a different
regime that will enable movement towards
peace but part of the problem Mr presid
let me ask wait I have to clear this
point with all the respect yes of course
it was Hamas who destroyed the
electricity lines of Gaza by shooting
these missiles it was Hamas who
destroyed the water infrastructure of
Gaza by shooting these missiles Israel
is supplying water Israel is enabling
humanitarian Aid despite the fact that
not one detail came about the hostages
who are there
now in in in Gaza 240 of them not one
people are asking themselves time and
again how come with all these Hypocrites
all around the world how come none of
them bother to say you know what
humanitarian Aid give information about
the hostages release the hostages it
can't go this way you'll tell me of
course you know the civilians are not to
blame fine if the civilians are not to
blame then please enable Israel to upro
these terrorists
[Applause]
[Music]
e
he
[Music]
will there be any ceasefire or
humanitarian pors if the hostages are
not
released so first and foremost you know
I'm a head of state I don't enjoy any
any executive powers this is under all
of this including the war cabinet is
under the domain of the government the
emergency cabinet the United cabinet of
national Unity under the leadership of
prime minister netan they are discussing
all of this including with our friends
and allies all throughout the world who
understand the the tragedy understand
the challenge and understand the ideas
of how do we aim to get out of it
but we are not dealing with rational
enemies it's not an enemy that you have
certain rules of the Geneva Convention
you are dealing with Psychopaths you are
dealing with a psychopathic leader who
has driven his people into the abyss
unfortunately it's extremely painful let
me tell you I care about Gaz and
children I truly do but with all du
respect first and foremost I have to
defend our people we have to to defend
the Israeli Nation we've gone through
atrocities this war was coerced upon us
we did not want to go to war we are not
a warmongering nation we're a peac
loving Nation say that mrend our hands
peace again and again and we get
missiles on our head and hypocritic
comments by leaders from all around all
all sorts of figures from around the
world never been here one day never
looked in the eyes of families who've
gone through the worst of atrocities but
let me let me throw this back at you
which is
the the comments of amihai eliyahu a
far-right minister in the Israeli
government who's just been suspended
after suggesting Israel may use nuclear
weapons against Gaza that's one way he
said that's an option he also said there
are no non-combatants in Gaza and the
Palestinians should move to Ireland or
the desert those are incredibly incend
and inflamat remarks and if you're a
Palestinian or if you're an Arab and you
hear a member of Israel's government
talking about nuking Gaza then you think
that there is a callous disregard for
human life in Gaza don't
you so that's a a words of rubbish by
someone who has no Authority no
knowledge and nor involvement in the
real decision making process it is very
regrettable and U prime minister
nany immediately denied it and took
action uh towards this Minister and
called him now to a a call where he's
going to explain to him how wrong he is
it is absolutely absurd and nobody
really gives any importance to these
words of
rubbish let's turn to some other words
which I don't think are rubbish but are
certainly uh worth uh mentioning to you
President Obama the former American
president said the Israeli government's
decision to cut off food water and
electricity to a captive civilian
population threatens not only to worsen
the growing humanitarian crisis it could
further Harden Palestinian attitude for
Generations erode Global support for
Israel play into the hands of Israel's
enemies and undermine long-term efforts
to achieve peace and stability in the
region and if you want to solve the
problem he says then you have to take in
the whole truth and you have to admit
nobody's hands are clean all of us are
complicit to some degree do you agree
with
him so President Obama I don't know when
he wrote and made that statement because
there is a major supply of food water
and humanitarian Aid to Gaza it flows in
it has been increased dramatically I met
with Secretary of State Tony blinkin on
Friday the he met with the Israeli
cabinet he discussed it and there is a
dramatic increase I met with the under
secretary of the United Nations in is in
my office last week and he thanked
Israel for these enormous humanitarian
steps forward
so I think the situation we which we
monitor on an hourly basis is much more
reasonable than you depict it and yes I
don't shy away from the pains and
sufferings of many people but at the end
of it all let's understand the situation
you cannot enable the Israeli nation
which is in shelters to go to return to
the same reality which was before the
7th of October we cannot first of all
people deserve to go back to their homes
why would they go to their homes if they
know their neighbors wants to swallow
them again withous Terr I agree with
that Mr President so so that so that
that the real issue here is that I think
the International Community needs to
tell all the supporters of Hamas all the
Arab Nations who Express uh support for
Hamas or Arab leaders or other leaders
and tell them you are to blame you are
to blame because you're enabling this
evil regime to come back again rather
than removing the evil regime finally
and enabling a rebuilding of a uh a
decent life for the Palestinian people
but you talk about the fact that Israeli
people want to go back to their homes
and of course they do and absolutely
their safety was removed from them the
depravity of October the 7th has caused
huge trauma to not just people in Israel
but Jewish people around the world I
completely get that but what do gazan
people do over a million have been
displaced from their homes if you could
just explain to me how do the gazan
people come back to their homes if
they've all been obliterated in the
north of
Gaza they will be able to rebuild their
homes like in the past it's not the
first time that they were under War
unfortunately it's extremely tragic but
you don't give me an answer to how
exactly am I going to live with the fact
that in their homes and they and they
saw these missiles from from their homes
they saw the terrorists coming out of
their homes they saw the tunnels dug in
their homes they saw their mosque being
filled they saw the hospitals the
hospitals which were financed by so many
countries including EU countries and
other countries become the center of
command of this terror attack this
terrorist organization meaning giving no
hope to them to their children and
grandchildren hopefully when this end
end these terrible circumstances end
this horrific circumstances end we will
be able to offer hope to the
Palestinians in Gaza to go back rebuild
their homes and finally have decent
lives with a different regime that will
enable progress and peace in the region
like we all need to
have final question many people would
agree with you that Hamas has to go
before any peace uh can be achieved but
many people also including many Israelis
according to latest polls believe that
it cannot be achieved with prime
minister netan who's still in office
either many think that what happened on
October the 7th was a catastrophic
failure of security and defense and the
buck should stop with him you yourself
have said before about Netanyahu I'm not
sure he has the guts to do it with
regards to moving towards peace and a
two-state solution should prime minister
Netanyahu step down
you know I'm the head of state as
president of the state the political
system has its own processes I made
clear in a national speech from the
Parliament that day the day after the
war will come where all these issues
will be discussed we are a vibrant
democracy we don't shy away from
anything but right now we're all United
we're all United in one goal we must
return the hostages back back we must
overcome and Prevail against our enemies
and we must bring peace and security to
our borders and our peoples this is my
only aim at this point Mr President I
really appreciate you giving me so much
time more than you plan to and I
acknowledge that and I appreciate it and
thank you very much indeed for joining
me today thank you very
[Music]
much
we're here good morning everybody hope
you're well thanks for joining us you're
watching the independent republic of mik
GRA right here on talk TV welcome to
Friday night with Nadine here on prime
time we like to speak to the business
people behind big moments good evening
I'm P Morgan uncensored in New York City
very impressive well
played I'm three days into the job what
have I done wrong yeah and your face
just starred out at me me and you
conquer time who wins you do you know
what I love about talk today we do it
all sunak sella
scon are you actually speech rating for
R I'm so rich frankly uh I'm going to
take the side of boozed up Brits against
these pomp what you mean you're not
going to support mayor Jose L not stop
panding to the n to the naysayers and
The National Society for the
preservation of the habitat of the
Lesser spotted M the problem lies in the
bureaucracy it's almost like highly paid
consults don't really know what they're
doing the first thing they teach you in
weather school is never confuse dog
walkers with Doggers Twitter you sons of
can you please reinstate my account
thank you there's a threat that you'd be
worried about so are you saying that
you're being overwhelmed that you're
inundated we are really working hard for
you and we're just asking patients to be
p